DAVID MCCLUSKY: Hey everyone.
My name is David McClusky.
And I'm a solutions engineer
with the Google Maps API team.
So as a solutions
engineer, I work
with Google's top
customers and partners
to help them solve
their business
problems with the power
of the Google Maps API.
So as Monica and Paul
mentioned, location intelligence
has become
increasingly important
to businesses of all sizes.
But only now are they really
available to businesses
of any size.
So you don't need to be an Uber
or an Amazon to take advantage
of location intelligence.
Any startup, any company can
build a platform on Google Maps
through the Google Maps API.
So I'm going to tell you
a little bit about some
of the APIs that Paul showed
you on a previous slide,
how they can be used in
a real life situation.
So I'm going to show
you a demo today that
demonstrates how a small company
can use location intelligence.
This is a fictional
coffee delivery
service called Coffee Pop.
And I'm going to
show you how they
can use the API to
drive better engagement,
streamline their operations,
and deliver greater satisfaction
to their customer base.
OK, so Coffee Pop,
what is Coffee Pop?
So this is a small,
again, fictional coffee
and cake delivery service.
I stress fictional
because last time
we had people trying to
download the app on their phone
and order coffee, and it
wasn't working out for them.
So Coffee Pop, they brew
coffee out of barista trucks.
They have a bicycle
riding workforce
that delivers coffee and cake
to people at their own location
on demand.
And then they can move
their barista trucks around
to better optimize their
service area to maximize
the number of customers.
So therefore they need to
connect their customers,
riders, and delivery trucks
together in real time
to keep everyone informed
about current operations
and the itinerary and
allow management to keep
an eye on the entire operation.
So to do this, they built
three separate applications,
one for the customers,
one for the riders,
and one for the managers.
So what does the
management team do?
So they have an app
to view and improve
the real time performance
of their entire operation
in real time.
The customers have
an application
so they can place an
order for coffee and cake
at their location.
And then the
delivery riders have
an app so they know when
there is an order ready
and to get routed
to the customer.
So I'm going to show you how
each one of these applications
can be built with
the Google Maps APIs.
All right, so this is
our management dashboard.
So this provides a
view for management
into the entire operation
of their business.
So we have things here on
this dashboard like customer
satisfaction scores, the
number of active orders,
the percent of orders that
are late or behind schedule.
I can see recent feedback.
You know, someone says three
stars, my coffee was on time.
Someone says one star, you
were three minutes late.
I can also view a map.
So this map gives me
a live, real time view
into everything that's going
on in my delivery zone.
So what I have
here in the middle,
this icon here represents
my barista truck.
This is where we're
brewing the coffee.
So I can click on it and I
can view our entire delivery
service area.
So this polygon
here represents--
it's what we call an isochron.
It's everywhere you can drive
within 15 minutes in this case.
So we want to set up a
delivery zone in real time
to ensure that all
of our customers
can be serviced
within 15 minutes.
So we're using real
time traffic data
to generate this in real time.
Let's look at some
of these other icons
and what they represent.
So here we have
a delivery rider.
I can click and zoom on him.
So this is one of
our bicycle riders.
And I can view what
his current task is.
So he's right now tasked
to go pick up coffee
at a barista truck
and then deliver it
to this customer over here.
I can also see these icons.
You see the little happy faces.
And if I zoom, yeah, there's
some frowns over here.
These are customers that
have already been serviced
but are either happy or unhappy.
So I see over here I have
a couple unhappy customers.
So then I want to dig down
and try to investigate, why
were these customers unhappy?
Was their orders wrong
or maybe they were late?
And I can bring in other
layers of information,
other sources of
information to try
to analyze what went wrong
here and better understand
the situation.
So one thing I can do is I can
turn on a real time traffic
layer right here in the app,
and I can view real time traffic
conditions to see if
maybe that's impacting
our service in this area.
Maybe I need to change our
service area a little bit.
So the next thing
I'm going to show
is now what the
Coffee Pop experience
looks like from the
perspective of a customer
from a mobile app.
So here I have an
iOS application.
This is built with the
Google Maps SDK for iOS.
And in this case what
the customer would
be doing and interacting
with this experience
is dragging the pin around
here to indicate where they
want their coffee delivered to.
Typically this is just going
to be their existing location.
So we get their location
from the device and say,
this is where I want
the coffee delivered to.
But perhaps you're on
your way to the park
and you want your
coffee delivered there.
So you can move the map pin.
Now the interesting thing here
is the number you see here
at the bottom of the screen.
So this is the time estimate.
Now a lot of things are going
into this time estimate.
It's the amount
of time that it's
going to take the delivery
rider to get to the barista
truck, the amount
of time it's going
to take to process the order and
then get that order over here
to the customer.
And so it's doing an
assignment from the orders
to the delivery riders in
real time in an automated
fashion behind the scenes.
So there's no dispatcher
here involved.
This is all just happening
in an automated fashion.
So now that I know
my time estimate,
I can click to place my order.
I can say I want some
coffee, some cake.
I click Confirm.
It's been assigned
to a delivery rider.
I can see a map.
I get time estimate.
And I can click Order Now.
And then now I can monitor, in
real time, that delivery driver
as they come to
deliver me my coffee.
So I can see what's
going on here.
And then I will now show
you the third application.
So this is the application
that the delivery riders
would have with them
on their mobile phone.
So in this case this is an
Android-based application
using our Android API.
So the first thing
that it would do
is detect that the
delivery rider is inside
one of the active barista
truck delivery zones.
And once it is, once
that rider is there,
they are allowed to sign
into the application.
And instantly they're
matched up with a job
that's waiting for them.
So they can accept the job and
they can view the active job.
And in this case,
it doesn't really
actually the most
sense just to be
assigned to one delivery job.
It could be several.
So you want to go to a barista
truck, pick up several orders,
and then deliver them all.
So our Directions APIs being
used here behind the scenes.
And what that's
doing is actually
doing waypoint optimization.
So it's routing them in
the most efficient route
to these multiple destinations.
They can view the-- first
thing I need to select a job,
activate a job.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is it doing the
traveling salesman algorithm?
DAVID MCCLUSKY: It's doing
a variation of the traveling
salesman problem.
So in this case it's one
worker and up to-- we
can do up to several
dozen waypoints in this.
It's not doing
hundreds or thousands
of waypoints, which becomes
very computationally intensive.
But with a smaller subset,
yeah, we can do that.
So the driver's given
a route, and he's
given the set of
directions to go to and do
those multiple deliveries.
And when the
deliveries are done,
you can mark them as complete.
Or what you can
do is actually use
the location from
the device itself.
So if he's actually
traveling around,
it could detect that
the driver has entered
into the same zone as the
customer location and said,
hey, that delivery's been made.
Mark those jobs as complete.
So this is just
a few of the ways
you can take advantage
of the Google Maps APIs
to build out an entire business
in an automated fashion.
So it doesn't require
much infrastructure.
It doesn't require servers.
It doesn't require data centers.
You can build this all
in the cloud with just
a few applications,
and really power
your business with location.